vertragsunterzeichnung bei der
österreichischen niederlassung von
general dynamics in wien simmering das
österreichische bundesheer bestellt 30
pandur evolution radpanzer die von 2022
bis 2023 ausgeliefert werden technische
fortschritte und auch die erkenntnisse
aus den langjährigen auslandseinsätzen
hat man es daher bewogen diese nach
beschaffung von weiteren 30
mannschaftstransporter mehr als 100
millionen euro durchzuführen da der
kulturrevolution ein rein
österreichisches produkt ist freut man
sich auch über den erhalt von
arbeitsplätzen in allen neuen
bundesländern durch diesen auftrag hier
haben wir 140 mitarbeiter standort wir
werden durch den auftrag auch um zehn
prozent aufstocken nicht behalten können
und weiters ist es wichtig dass wir auch
keine produktionsauslastung bis mitte
2003 und 20 mit diesem auftrag haben
nochmal in zeiten wie diesen denke ich
ein sehr guter ausblick wenn sie daran
denken dass die wirtschaft von hier bei
70 prozent liegt das 179 bei 3 200
firmen aus allen bundesländern an diesem
projekt beteiligt sind dann sieht man
mehr als nur die bestellten fahrzeuge
werden bei infanterie verbänden zum
einsatz kommen